who remembers this bastard this cokehead
this crackhead who used the funding from
his right-wing followers to fund this
coke addiction you witnessed last week
in Israel has everything to do with
[Music]
Islam
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala who remembers this
bastard this cockhead this crackhead who
used the funding from his rightwing
followers to fund this coke addiction
you witnessed last week in Israel has
everything to do with Islam so Kamas
heah the Taliban CA k
C shabab you see all these groups who
misinterpret the Quran this very clown
who was crapping himself when I went to
the vicinity of his house and the reason
I didn't go to his house is not cuz I'm
scared of this Punk this coward bastard
it's because of respect to his family
and he bugged out and went crazy doxing
me and crying like a little boy and
didn't even come face to face with me I
had to track him down and he's now
talking about paltin and this that and
this is what the Quran teaches you scum
bastard we condemn the king of any
innocent people for that matter whoever
it stand by Israel Hamas America great
Great Britain whoever it is I want to
ask you a question bastard if your house
which I came to the vicinity of if I
came into your house and killed your
kids and kicked you out not kicked you
out actually I told you to go and live
in your flipping shed yeah and every
single day I was oppressing you mocking
you belittling you killing your family
members one by one you bastard a simple
question what would you Bast bastard do
if that was the case if your children
were blown into pieces your wife was
killed you were persecuted for 75 years
what would you do you bastard answer my
question you have no damn sympathy for
what those people are going through who
have been dropped their land stolen who
have been killed if you was in their
situation you would have been doing
things that would be against every
single international law we are there
for these innocent Palestinians who are
being massacred nearly 3 400 children
blown to pieces you bastard you have
kids if this happened to your kids I
will be the first one to come and defend
you and your family yes that you deem
Islam says that we should kill them or
find them yeah I would be defending your
kids with my own life so that doesn't
happen because that is oppression and
this is what Islam teach us so you
bastard next time you open your mouth be
just you Shameless cokehead Islam n is
establishing a Masid and a community
center if you donate to build this
Masjid Allah will insh build a house for
you in Jenna with bricks of gold and
silver every person who prais in this
Masid every child that memorizing the
Quran you will insh share in that reward
donate now guys and do not
[Music]
delay